what's popping Rebels it's me Mt and
while Ahsoka episode 7 has got Ahsoka
Sabine and Ezra back together again for
a Jedi group hug the biggest question
that this episode has got everyone
wondering is just where in the cryptic
hell is balen skull's bearded asshe
headed like what is motivating balon's
goal like what the hell does he want
well let us try to figure it all for
ourselves my nerd babies because clearly
Balin is not trying to give anyone a
straight answer all right so basically I
believe that Balin is looking for a
little something called Cosmic knowledge
but why do I think this well in order to
attempt to answer that we should
probably take a cue from Grand Admiral
FR by seeking to gather as much
information as we can about our
mysterious bearded man friend so that we
can take our best swing when it comes to
trying to predict his next move so what
do we know about balin's cult well we
know that it used to be a general in the
Jedi Order when he fought in the Clone
Wars and that is very evident simply by
the way Balin carries himself choosing a
very reserved fighting style by refusing
to fight unless absolutely necessary
very much reflects his past Jedi
training on corusant and because of this
Balin is a man who has a significantly
strong respect for life and truly
despises the act of taking a life even
when he believes that he has to and if
it wasn't for Ahsoka being a Potential
Threat to his mysterious plans Balin
would have much rather preferred that
Ahsoka lived because he truly believes
that there are too few Jedi in the
universe following Palpatine's Purge
which establishes that J is a man who
misses the Jedi's influence on the
Galaxy even though he himself refuses to
continue practicing the Jedi way in a
past Ahsoka episode Balin tells Shin
that he misses the Jedi Order not for
the Arrogant overly religious cult that
they became due to their own willful
ignorance towards how their own deep
fears of the dark side were manipulating
them into becoming soldiers but for the
ideals that the Jedi were initially
supposed to stand for that's what he
liked more the overall preservation of
life and the spreading of enlightened
wisdom Bal seems to embody these
peacekeeping ideals quite well for the
most part you know when he's not
murdering people especially in the realm
of enlightened wisdom as Balin seems to
be a man who has an immense thirst for
knowledge and has imparted as much
wisdom into his Apprentice as he could
and this is evident in his wise parting
words to Shin in episode 7 when he tells
her that an impatience for victory will
mean certain defeat which is of course
actually a real life quote from French
King Louis the 14th a man that values
wisdom is also very likely a man with a
deep respect for history which is yet
another thing that we know about balen
skull and something that both balen and
gr anal Ron actually have in common
despite their goals in the series being
completely different balin's obsession
with history is a major driver for him
and his main mission appears to be
tightly linked to that Obsession as he
cryptically tells Shin in an earlier
episode that he is searching for a type
of power that will somehow Grant him the
ability to break a never-ending cycle of
Star Wars that the Galaxy keeps
suffering under throughout history a
historical cycle that is directly
influenced by the overall cosmic power
struggle between the forces of darkness
and the forces of light After
experiencing the fall of the Jedi Order
firsthand balen skull turned to the
history books in an attempt to try to
make sense of his crumbling reality and
while being well read in past events is
extremely wise because those who are
ignorant of the past are doomed to
repeat it it stops being a wise action
when one lets their obsession with the
past give them a crippling fear of the
future and I believe that specific fear
is what has led baland down his own
dark-sided path I mean hell even the
legendary Luke Skywalker accidentally
makes the same damn mistakes in the
sequel Trilogy when his own obsession
with studying the ancient Jedi text is
what actually gives him his deep fear of
accidentally creating another Darth
Vader and it is that fear that
manipulated Luke into almost killing a
young Ben Solo in his moment of weakness
which then caused the very thing that he
feared to happen the creation of a new
Darth Vader via kylo Ren but anyways
this all being said knowing that Balin
is a well- read former Jedi with a deep
understanding of Galactic history who
has adopted the darker side of the force
as his ally I believe that Balin is
searching for a special type of power
that he's basically always been
searching for ever since the Jedi fell
knowledge because in Star Wars knowledge
is power and no I'm not trying to sound
like an ad for your local library this
is actually a concept that has been
established in already and one that Ezra
himself learned firsthand right before
he clashed his Sabers with the Sith Lord
Darth Vader in the rebel series the
season 2 finale of that series takes
place within an ancient temple on the
abandoned Sith planet of malachor a dark
side planet that Ezra Ahsoka and Canan
are led to by the force in order to find
and use the cosmic knowledge within to
find the secret to destroying the Sith
once and for all there's something here
for us yeah something to help us Stop
The Inquisitor
knowledge Ahsoka you said we're here to
find knowledge what kind of knowledge
The Forbidden kind to defeat your enemy
you have to understand
them and that knowledge came in the form
of a pyramid-shaped Sith holocron
located within a large pyramid of a Sith
temple on malore a Sith Temple that also
doubled as a secret super weapon that
could wipe out a ton of life if fallen
into the wrong hands the total
devastation of ancient Jedi and Sith
Warriors who were turned into Ash at the
base of the temple itself was direct
proof of this Sith Temple's destructive
capabilities but more on that specific
detail later because these dead bodies
are very important that Sith holocron
that Ezra found and the knowledge held
within it would end up being the key to
activating that super weapon but Darth
Maul conveniently does not tell Ezra
that when he tricks Ezra into placing
the Sith holocron into the obelisk
activation chamber at the top of the
pyramid now let's watch what happens
when he does that who comes
for Ezra uh Ezra Bridger I was told this
holocron is the key to knowledge indeed
Ezra Bridger and do you know what
knowledge is tell me knowledge is
power the mysterious presence within the
Sith Temple itself essentially tells
Ezra that the cosmic Knowledge from
within the Sith holocron was the key to
the temple super weapons destructive
power and this is the very same type of
cosmic knowledge that I believe Balin
could potentially be searching for on
the planet of peridia but just how can a
tiny pyramid-shaped holocron of
knowledge contain that much power and
how could the answer to that question
possibly explain to us how Ahsoka got to
the world Between Worlds a few episodes
ago well in Star Wars holocrons are
basically objects that held a massive
concentration of the force and the Jedi
and Sith each had their own types of
holocrons with the Jedi holocrons having
a blue and circular form and Sith
holocrons being red and more triangular
in shape because of this massive
concentration of force energies that
these objects hold holocrons have a deep
connection to an aspect of the force
called The Cosmic Force which in Star
Wars is the part of the force that is
the number one source of knowledge in
the cosmos from the cosmos like the very
Stars themselves and it's basically how
Force users can see the future through
their dreams and visions and it's what
Balin accesses when he closes his eyes
and reaches out for insight and
information from the force holocrons are
just tiny houses for these chunks of
ultra powerful knowledge energy from the
Wellspring of super valuable and
game-changing secret knowledge that is
the cosmic Force however this being the
case though not technically a holocron
itself the star map that Ahsoka grabs
directly and burns her hand on in
episode 4 should technically be a type
of force holocron as it was also a
container of a huge concentration of
cosmic Force energy that held secret
Cosmic knowledge and that knowledge
manifested as the pathway to peridia for
Morgan as well as a Gateway for Ahsoka
to teleport to the world between World
itself when the energies within that
ball went into her body because you see
the cosmic Force appears to be the
reason for the very existence of the
realm of absolute knowledge known as the
world Between Worlds as that entire
realm appears to be a direct
manifestation of the cosmic Force itself
it's basically Cosmic Force Topia which
is why it's essentially a giant
Crossroads filled with the knowledge
that the visitor is looking for for
example after being teleported there by
the knowledge energy inside that star
map Ahsoka gained wisdom through the
cosmic Force when the cosmic Force
manifestation of Anakin Skywalker came
to teach her to not be ashamed of the
good man that Anakin was before he
became the monster Darth Vader Ezra also
gained wisdom through the world Between
Worlds when he was there in season four
of Star Wars Rebels when the cosmic
Force taught him the important lesson of
letting his master Kanan go through
ahsoka's intervention now I believe that
the very reason why Ezra was able to
pull Ahsoka from malachor into the world
Between Worlds in the first place was
specifically because the activated Sith
holocron on malachor opened up a Cosmic
Force doorway of knowledge for Ezra to
do so because the world Between Worlds
is the source of all secret knowledge in
the universe as a manifestation of the
cosmic force it makes sense that
powerful Cosmic Force objects like
holocrons and starm Maps can act as
gateways to the world between World
itself Ezra pulls Ahsoka into the world
Between Worlds from behind from a
triangular doorway because the Sith
holocron on malachor was directly behind
her in that moment the holocron is the
portal okay this this all being said I
believe that balen skull is looking for
this specific type of cosmic Force
knowledge power in order for him to tap
into the world Between Worlds to craft a
new beginning in this new Galaxy as its
new all powerful and all- knowing ruler
while fron and shin have their fun back
in his home Galaxy and I believe that
Balin is specifically using his deep
knowledge of History to do this
specifically his knowledge of the
history of an ancient race of powerful
force wielders called the Zeo introduc
in the Star Wars Jedi Fallen order video
games if you watched my last Ahsoka
video you'll remember how I brought up
how the temple thrawn and the great
mothers are stationed at is covered in
the ancient language of these zepo
people and how the influence of the
ancient Dark Side zepo Sage kujet who
ruled the nin sister planet of damir
long before the nin sisters could be
connected to this new Temple on peridia
well I would later learn from Super
Smart Twitter user at Tommy jwall how
the outer walls of this Temple also
contains upside down text written in the
Sith language of katat text that
translates into praise kuat ruler of all
may his rain last for all time and major
shout outs to Ryan Ary of screen crush
and his Dope video on the Zeo that
pointed me to Tommy's Direction both of
you guys are awesome this is super
significant because the Zeo rac's crazy
deep knowledge of the force and all of
its Secrets is exactly the type of real
power that Balin is actually looking for
because remember how I mentioned that
scene of Jedi and Sith Warriors that
were turned into ash from the power of
cosmic knowledge that powered the
malachor super weapon a very similarly
creepy scene can be found within ket's
tomb on damir where the bodies of a
bunch of zepho rebels that the
dark-sided kuet turned into Ash can
still be seen thousands of years later
by cestus when he Journeys into ket's
old castle turned tomb this deeply
implies to me that the dark-sided kuet
found a way to access the same type of
destructive Cosmic Force knowledge power
power that the Sith used with their
super weapon on malachor and used it on
his own people when he used to live on
damir during the age of the zepo this
all being said since peridia is also
strongly implied to be a zepo planet
with strong links to this very same zepo
Sage I believe that Balin is looking to
possess that very same level of cosmic
power that kuet used to keep his entire
race in line so that Balin can use this
near infinite knowledge to craft this
new Galaxy that he's journeyed to into
his own image and to sure that this new
Galaxy is one that is free of the war
and suffering that plagues the history
of the Galaxy that he left behind like
that's all I think bin wants the power
to enact Real Change by becoming an all-
knowing all powerful god- type figure
much like the dark-sided kujet of old
but with far less misery and suffering
because at the end of the day Balin is
just a guy who wants peace in his Galaxy
and he's chasing the power of the cosmic
Force to do just that because knowledge
is power but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you to
Follow Me @ Mass entertainment on
Twitter and Instagram or wherever I am
on the internet but most importantly do
not forget to subscribe to heavy
spoilers today so that you don't miss
out on anything that we put out and if
you have not watched Paul's breakdown of
this last episode of Ahsoka do that
right now because my boy Paul we killing
it with these breakdowns but anyways
thank you guys again for watching you
guys are amazing and I'll see you guys
next time bye